وحطيته المترو في باريس مقفله خميس اسود
تشهده البلاد بسبب اضراب ينظمهم موظفوا
قطاع النقل تسبب بشلل تام في وسائل النقل
خطان فقط من اصل 15 من خطوط المترو
الفارسيه يعملان بشكل طبيعي لانهما
اوتوماتيكيان ولا يحتجان نساء اما الخطوط
المتبقيه فخمسه منها على الاقل توقفت بشكل
كامل فيما تعمل البقيه في ساعه ذروا فقط
ويتزمن هذا الاضراب الذي يحمل مطالب زياده
وتحسين ظروف العمل مع تظاهرات دعى اليها
الاتحاد العام للعمل وقال ان نحو 200 نقطه
تظاهر خارجت في عمومي انحاء البلاد
استجابه لهذه الدعوه
قليل من الاشخاص يحتكرون الثروه وفي الوقت
ذاته هناك اشخاص يعملون من اجل كسب قوت
معيشتها هذا ليس مجرد تسير لامور المعيشه
بالمحاوله للنجاه من هذا الوضع
تمديده وجعله اضرابا مفتوحا هو امر وارد
لكنه ينتظر نتائج المفاوضات مع الحكومه
العربيه باريس